hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt sah
mir und ich wir wollen heute rabatt
google muffins eigentlich packen
aber unsere google hoc vom nicht
gefunden deswegen gibt's rabatt donuts
oder ok in dieser tonart form
man kann natürlich auch eine andere
muffin form nehmen oder einfach so eine
kleine mini coupe form finde ich ganz
süß aber irgendwie haben sie nicht
gefunden
auf jeden fall ist es ein ganz normaler
rührteig ganzen rabatt stücke mit drin
und später werden sie noch schön
dekoriert mit einer blume und ich zeige
euch jetzt direkt die zutaten
wir brauchen dafür 100 gramm butter 100
gramm puderzucker vanille extrakt zweier
eine prise salz 100 milliliter milch 160
gramm mehl einen halben teelöffel
backpulver eine bio zitrone 100 km
autobahn und eine stange rabatte sind
etwa 130 gramm
ich nehme mich direkt den rhabarber und
zwar brauchen wir davon 100 gramm also
100 gramm geschätztes gewicht
mit den jetzt erstmal ab
nein
jetzt schreiben wir den rhabarber in
kleine würfel wir machen das jetzt hier
kurz dem alligator umsatz zu machen wie
ich schon einmal drücken und dann
jetzt nehme ich den puderzucker und ihm
da jetzt einen esslöffel davon und
vermischt dem rhabarber
da kann nämlich der so ein bisschen saft
raus lassen
so kann schon die backform einfachen so
denn das hier alle seite steht kann ich
helfen
jetzt kommen den teig zubereiten geben
dafür die butter in einer rührschüssel
da kommt genau bisschen mal in echt
fragt dazu recht schon dann der
puderzucker und studios noch das salz
rhein geben dann wird das ganze kurz
verrührt das ganze und sollte dann weiß
schaumig sein
die butter zucker macht jetzt schön
cremig jetzt kommen die eier mit dazu so
lange rühren bis sich derzeit gut
verbunden
berühre ich backpulver und mädel
miteinander und dann darfst du das
wieder mit da dazugeben okay dann noch
ein bisschen milch nicht sein dass er
nicht die komplette mit benötigt je
nachdem wie groß die eier nämlich vorher
waren und ich kann vorher noch die
zitronenschale abreiben
dann kommt die auch mit dazu kannst du
die maschine ausmachen
kommen die zitronenschale noch mit 1 und
dann reibe ich noch das marzipan frei
damit rennt und flanken und jetzt könnt
ihr mal schauen wenn der teig nicht
feucht genug ist und noch so fest ist
kommt noch ein bisschen milch dazu
samira hat die backform es doch gefunden
also packe ich meine da drinnen und
doppel steiner noch hier drin oder ok
aber zuerst einmal gebe ich jetzt sorgt
der rhabarber mit dem teig für samira
habe ich schon zwei drei esslöffel teig
weg gelegt die mich nämlich gern ohne
rhabarber und der bawag kommt dem
rhabarber softie mitteilen
und wenn man jetzt übrigens den roten
rhabarber nimmt dann ist er etwas süßer
der grüne rasen so ein bisschen
säuerlicher jetzt sagst du an machen
auf stufe eins ist doch ganz gut
verrühren bis sich alles verbunden hat
und meines der teig auch schon fertig
den teig finde ich jetzt mit einem eis
funktionäre ein die formen fühle ich
jetzt etwa bis dreiviertel und dann
werden die muffins direkt im backofen
bei 190 grad ober unterhitze gebacken
je nachdem was für eine backform jetzt
hat als ich werde jetzt etwa 15 bis 20
minuten backen
samir astronaut formen werden etwa nur
15 minuten brauchen
die roma finsternis abwickelt man kann
sie jetzt entweder so lassen oder so wie
bei mir noch einen gusto aufschrei
streichen
bei mir kommt jetzt noch ein ganz
kleiner sodass zuckerguss drauf ich habe
225 gramm puderzucker und ein paar
teelöffel papa was oft das verriet jetzt
hier miteinander
man kann aber auch zum beispiel einfach
nur super drauf stehen euch den cover
samt das passt es gut
vor allem stand der große leicht rosa
und sie dann richtig hübsch aus von der
konsistente ist der große ziemlich
dickflüssig den streiche ich da jetzt
nur obendrauf
man kann nämlich am rahmen auch so
leicht runter drauf teufeln und winter
trocken
jetzt hat dieser noch die blumen drauf
setzen weil es nämlich optisch und
geschmacklich wirklich gut passt setzen
wir dann noch so opladen blümchen drauf
kann es zum beispiel auch so ein
bisschen seitlich
außerdem mache es ganz schnell
eigentlich dekoriert als die war
wirklich schnell gebackenen schnell
dekoriert waren auch nur ganz wenige
zutaten leider stimmt ist nicht da zu
probieren
aber ich zeige euch einfach mal wieso
macht mich das auch wissen wie so ein
muffin von der konsistenz her aussieht
an dem da unten jetzt klaus nicht
wirklich meine blumen oder h
doch geklappt also im innern sieht man
richtig schön dieser rhabarber stück und
der teig ist auch sehr kompakt weil ich
ja marzipan mit dabei habe und das
wirklich sehr saftig und aromatisch also
ich finde sie menschlich sehr lecker
haben wollen schon ein gegessen und
falls ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt dann geht auch meinen blog auf
facebook de
da stets noch mal ganz genau wer es
gerne etwas süßer mag nimmt gerne den
roten rhabarber ansonsten passt der
grüne wirklich geschmacklich auch sehr
gut mit dazu genau samira bringt jetzt
auch ihre donuts die deko reden wir
jetzt auch noch fertig und ich wünsche
mir ganz viel spaß beim nach backen oder
papa guck mal hier